it's like i've been thinking lately that
the um the human experience
is really simple yet
complicated or and complicated because
it's simple in that everything in your
reality is
is kind of reflecting you back to you or
showing you
you through like a trigger or through a
judgment
or through somebody else projecting and
how it makes
it's all information about you yet it's
complicated because you can't see
you you need other people to see you
because since it's an original sort of
like
root programming you can't know the
program it's already there
like the program is already installed
and so you can't
tell what program you're running because
it's on autopilot and so you're like oh
wow you need all and you get all this
feedback from other people it's really
you experiencing yourself
wow yeah that's a great way to put that
yeah that makes a lot and that makes a
lot of sense that's totally applicable
i relate to that but yeah that makes a
lot of sense
i i do it it one of one of my biggest
breakthroughs was
um was when we had the conversation
of um you know like
you just try i just shrugged off like
what do you love about yourself it's
like what what what
what that how how do i even what what
does it mean
and uh and we had to again kind of
reverse engineer into that as well
you know okay we'll pick pic pick your
you know
your favorite person someone you love
deeply what what what is
it that you love about them and you you
name those things and those top five
things
are actually things that you you you see
in that
person because you see it in yourself um
and that was a wild like groundbreaking
thing for me because i was like holy
crap i
okay i get it that makes a lot of sense
and and the negative is true as well you
know
i've that's really helped me because
anytime i'm i'm
i'm annoyed i'm saying this knowing that
i'm in the room with someone who's
experienced me at my best and my
absolute
worst but um but it has
really helped me understand people who
you know who i have a hard time getting
along with you know or have a hard time
working with or
um or i mean just
just people in general like it you know
um if there's something that i
that bothers me about them chances are
it's just because it bothers me about
myself it's something that i really want
to work on so
yeah or something you deny that's so
it's the common one like when we judge
like when i judge something in someone
i'm like
oh yeah that's because i'd never allow
myself to do that or act like that
or whatever it may be like it's a denial
that's like
totally where my judgments come in i
mean there's a lot of ways to unpack it
for sure but it's it's it's a
fascinating thing the human experience
is so fascinating and so
you know i i think that while i know
we're not talking directly about music
but
it's this depth that creates it
right it's this depth that um gives you
oh like a need almost really right like
it's there
it's therapeutic it's an outlet it's a
release and
so what do you think it is that um and
saying that it makes me
think about hits and hit songs and
you talking earlier about ones that you
know you push through because you really
believed in them
and you know can you
feel it is there
is there a feeling or is there some
awareness to
when you've created something that's
really special
you definitely feel it it's hard to
quantify
um which is i think the challenge of of
our our job
but a hundred percent you you know when
you've
communicated something to someone very
well how you know
i think i mean i guess i was speaking
generally i think when you're talking to
a friend you sort of walk away
um like you've spoken all of your truth
you know
and i think songs can can be the same
way even even considering the fact that
we're editing right
um you still have a purpose for the song
you start i start out with a title i
love
starting with titles and i've got you
know
thousands of voice memos of you know
music
things that happen on a piano or a
guitar or something i sing in the car
um and and i don't surprisingly have a
lot of
lyrical things but i think that's
because i kind of trained myself when i
first started songwriting because i knew
you know i have a scheduled
songwriting session with someone at 11
o'clock on tuesday
and i'm gonna have to recreate the
feeling i'm feeling on 3am on saturday
so i kind of got to a place where i like
sort of and that's that makes a lot of
sense
in the context of things but i held on
to a lot of emotions because i knew i'd
have to tap into them at some point so
um so it's sort of it starts with the
title and the title
is literally meant to be a trigger funny
enough
um and it sends you back there and i
think um the songs that are written by
myself happen
when they're supposed to happen they
happen in the moment um but the songs
that i've written with other people
you know they start by yourself and then
you continue them when you're in the
room with them and when you're scheduled
to be there so i think
knowing that and having those songs
there's a
feeling of totality and completion when
you walk away and you know that you've
shared all of your truth because
not only you're not just sculpting a
song you're expressing and
by by nature the the more tapped in you
are to that expression
the more honest you are with that
expression and the more of your truth
you allow
you can say a word
it's not the same as singing a word and
when you sing a word
um if you're tapped into it you can feel
it on the other end
of the line you can you can hear and
subconsciously we all know this that's
why we're drawn to certain songs and
we're not drawn to certain songs certain
songs feel calculated to us we don't
know
why they feel calculated but they do
they don't have an emotion on the other
end
and certain people you know um
can i can sing the simplest line and you
just
break you know or um or they can
take you know or you know there's pure
joy in certain songs that feel like
dance songs and there's also a reason
why dance songs you know sometimes these
happy songs only last
so long with us because there's only so
much of that that's actually there so
you know i think for me my feeling when
i know that i've really tapped into a
song i leave the studio and i just feel
like
um and it's not it's not purely about
like just me saying my truth i know that
by saying
by being fully present by being fully
truthful i also gave the words
the color that they needed and and i was
able to supply
the emotion behind that one note or that
note was chosen because there was a
motion behind it it wasn't just we
strung
these words together cleverly and then
we figured out how they fit in an
eight-bar phrase
um everything went into it and you sort
of walk away and it's honestly kind of
emotionally exhausting
when i leave a session that i feel like
i've done well i'm definitely just like
my days done